you know he told me he was a widower
that he had lost his wife and his
daughter I was a widow as well and that
I was flirtatious with him because it
was fun
to think that there was this person
over there in another country who found
me attractive and it was kind of
intriguing to me that wow I wonder if I
could find love again
and wouldn't that be nice
you've heard the voice of 68 year old
Karen Miller from California who shared
her story for the criminal podcast one
day a man named Gil Harper messaged her
on Facebook he said he was 63 years old
they had similar interests and they were
messaging non-stop even making plans to
meet in person
Karen shared the joyful news with her
sons
they checked Gil's account and realized
that he was a fake the mother's heart
was broken
people create fake virtual identities
for a variety of reasons you may come
across a virtual Persona on dating sites
or freelance sites where scammers can
also lurk sometimes fake virtual
identities are used by online trolls to
harass users with impunity without
attracting attention the internet and
social media are teaming with fake
accounts and attempts are being made to
deal with this however the problem is
still far from being solved in 2021 FTC
reported that in the past five years
people have lost a staggering 1.3
billion dollars to romance scams in 2021
losses hit a record 547 million dollars
for the year catfishing is a very
serious business in this video we will
conduct a small experiment and try to
create our own virtual identity using
available tools we don't want to teach
you anything bad we want to show how
easy it still is and how you should be
more Vigilant in the online jungle
this video was created by samsub the
verification platform we keep cyber
criminals out of your wallet but more
about us in a bit
foreign
let's start with a biography the minimum
biographical information is the person's
gender age name birth location and
residence when creating a biography it
may feel like a writer creating a
character for a new novel The activities
are very similar if your chosen gender
and age are different from your own you
will need to consider some of the
perceptions and behaviors of these
people a senior gentleman from
Birmingham will have different interests
favorite movies and music to a young
girl from Texas to can use someone we
know very well such as a parent or close
relative as a model of behavior and
perception for your virtual identity
many writers use this technique a lot
let's choose a name we're not going to
choose a rare name the more common a
name the better we'll have a chance of
remaining Incognito remember that first
and last names can give away a person's
origin and nationality okay let's say
our character is a 28 year old woman
called Amanda Laurie oh no there's too
many let's call her Amanda Taylor it's
one of the most common surnames in
England she was born on June the 16th
1995. as a place of birth and residence
it's best to choose one that is familiar
to us but we'll need to study the city
or area using Publications on the
internet and Google Maps in any case
it's better to choose a large
metropolitan area in smaller towns
people often know each other and there's
a better chance of meeting mutual
acquaintances let's say Amanda was born
and living in London in the borough of
Barnet located in the Northern parts of
the city remember the location of your
virtual identity determines its time
zone when will your character be active
on the internet the characters activity
and sleep times should coincide with the
local time where she or he lives at
least as far as day and night are
concerned now let's choose the
occupation we avoid using organizations
where it's easy for others to check
whether a person works there aramanda is
a freelance graphic designer who works
independently this occupation offers
flexibility creativity and allows your
virtual character to work on various
projects let's think whether our
character has a family or relatives
we'll make Amanda the only child of a
mother who has been long divorced from
her husband she is not married now we
need to think about interests and
hobbies as a designer Amanda has a
passion for design Visual Arts fashion
and creativity freelancing gives her the
freedom to work on different projects
collaborate with different people and
showcase her artistic skills it can
offer a good work-life balance and the
potential for personal growth
as a freelancer she can work from home
shared workspaces or even coffee shops
this allows her to focus more on her
personal Journey relationships and the
challenges in her life rather than her
career
the more detailed our character's
biography the more real she or he will
be to make our job easier we can use
various fake persona generators that
will randomly select biography and
hobbies for your character what a useful
instrument cool generator creates
detailed interests and hobbies for
virtual identity we can pick up
character traits from there if we want
to imitate another person in our posts
and Communications to create a fake
address we can use fakexy.com web
service however don't get carried away
with automatic generators as the
biographical facts they produce May
contradict each other it's much better
to do it manually even if it takes
longer the main thing is not to forget
all of this it will come in handy later
[Music]
if we surf the Internet from a computer
or laptop our privacy may be at risk you
know it already every computer has
characteristics by which you can be
identified on the network Mac address
video card type operating system version
screen resolution the operating system
and browser also have their own
fingerprints for our purposes therefore
it's best to use a virtual machine the
free Oracle virtualbox is suitable
install a clean copy of the operating
system on this virtual machine do not
register the OS with your existing
account to link to your email create a
new one remember to set the correct time
and time zone for your character's
location from now on use this virtual
machine and to access the internet on
behalf of your virtual identity to hide
real IP addresses we can use VPN
services or Tor the best option is to
set up a personal VPN server using the
services of virtual private server
rental companies if we use Tor or public
vpns some platforms May suspect that
we're not authentic and ask for identity
verification forcing us to provide an
additional recovery phone number so if
your virtual identities location is the
same as your real one you can instead
connect to the public internet in busy
places like Parks shopping malls and
cafes it's a good fit with a freelancer
image we've chosen for our character
however in addition to a computer our
virtual personality will need a cell
phone thank you
we need a phone number to receive a
verification SMS or call to register for
internet services before we can use the
account the best way to protect your
privacy is to buy a SIM card for cash
without ID verification if this option
is not available you can buy a SIM card
from a third-party provider such as
www.onesimcard.com they offer prepaid
international SIM cards that are quite
Anonymous you can even pay with Bitcoin
how to get an anonymous email we'll talk
about that a bit later we can also use
special applications to get virtual
numbers burner app the smartphone app
acts as an alternative phone number the
app can make or receive calls and send
SMS messages it uses a us or Canadian
number cover me app works like burner
offers a virtual phone number but claims
to secure your messages so that cover me
staff cannot read them hushed app works
like burner but offers International
numbers and calls not all numbers offer
the same features but most of them have
SMS and voice calling as avoid using the
same phone for both your everyday SIM
card and your virtual identity Sim every
mobile phone comes with an IMEI number
which can be thought of as your phone's
serial number Mobile operators track
IMEI numbers it's better to buy a used
mobile phone for our virtual identity
SIM card we'll get a cheap new phone
also avoid using dual SIM phones firstly
mobile operators will track both your
sim cards in the same place secondly the
applications installed on your
smartphone will give you away remember
that if both phones are switched on side
by side this will also remain in the
mobile operators databases however in
order to track geolocation it's
necessary to get your phone's location
history from the mobile operators and
you have to be a criminal or really
annoy the government that's not about us
is it
to register with most Services we need
an email address you can use protonmail
the most secure and Anonymous email
provider it does not require an
additional email address to register an
account but some Services may not accept
it it supports encryption and protects
emails from unauthorized access which is
why hackers love this service well all
people who value their privacy also
tutonota.com is a service that allows
you to create one free email with
sufficient privacy and encryption but
you must visit your inbox at least once
in six months otherwise it will
automatically be deleted this provider
also does not require an additional
email address and you can only use the
free email address for non-commercial
purposes otherwise you'll have to pay a
subscription fee it's also possible to
register a new mailbox with a regular
Public Service such as Gmail but with
the following precautions use a virtual
machine use vpm your second SIM card and
mobile phone as a modem or public Wi-Fi
in a busy location think of it as a
unique email address which could be your
virtual Persona name or part of his or
her first and last name not your real
name for more privacy to visit the
provider's website use one of the
private browsers we discussed in our
video
foreign
the most important characteristic of a
person is their appearance
speaking of fabricated appearances hi
everyone this is Lucas from samsup so a
bit about deep fakes photorealistic
defects are made using powerful machine
learning algorithms you may have heard
about synthetic fraud 2 which is when a
deep fake is used in some sort of
disinformation campaign that photo of
the Pope wearing a nice Balenciaga
jacket is one notable example of a
successful synthetic fraud attack at
some sub we can detect these things
instantly but it's not easy try our
Wacker deep fake game and see for
yourself link is in the description
below cheers we need to create an image
for our non-existent virtual person to
do this we can use the website this
person does not exist.com which uses
neural networks to create portraits of
non-existent people here we can choose a
single portrait of a person who matches
gender and age for our virtual identity
here are some other similar websites we
can use
boardhumans.com forward slash faces
unrealperson.com which facesreal.com
but we only have one photo not enough
for a real person
with a website generated.photos we can
generate several similar faces it's not
a free service but they do offer a
three-day trial oops but as Anonymous as
we thought optionally we can create a
set of photorealistic portraits from
scratch using neural networks such as
mid-journey if you like a neural network
generated person you can copy it to
other generated images each neural net
generated image has a seed a specific
numerical value that is used as a
reference point using this seed you can
create similar images based on the same
set of initial data first it is needed
to know the images seed simply send the
Bots an emoji in the shape of an
envelope the bot will report the
original images and the seed value in
personal messages you can then use it to
generate new images by adding dash dash
seed x to the prompt where X is the seed
you received in the previous step the
neural network will generate more
portraits with the same face but it's
too complicated it's much easier to use
face swapping software to get lots of
new photos we can use various online
services such as pixable.com forward
slash app forward slash face swapper or
we can install a face swapping app on
your smartphone face app youcam perfect
reface Snapchat face over face swap live
face swap Booth Face Changer 2
multi-face blender or another we can
also use photos that don't show the face
photos taken from behind photos of
similar people wearing dark glasses or
portrait based art such images can be
found on Photo stocks now with a virtual
person's biography email phone number
and a set of photos we can create a
credible profile on Facebook and
Instagram oh we still need to upload our
real photo for a verification we don't
want our Facebook profile to look like
it has just been created so we're going
to create some posts in the past to do
this we need a time machine or do we
under what's on your mind Amanda we
create a new post click on the publicity
button at the top and under who can see
your post select only me once the post
is created click on the three dots at
the right top and select edit date enter
a date from the past in the calendar
make several of these posts now we have
information in the feed for several
years
if we want to give Amanda more life of
her own we can give her a voice there
are two ways to do this firstly we can
use a voice changing application such as
merf.ai we record a voice message and
run it through the program which changes
the voice don't forget to write down all
the settings so that the voice doesn't
change next time secondly we can use
artificial intelligence which voices the
text we enter in different voices for
example bark this service is so
versatile that it can add coughs pauses
and other things to make the voice
really come alive and it supports
different languages we can make a video
with Amanda using deep fake this is a
rather complex technology that requires
a lot of computing resources and some
knowledge one of the best free tools for
making deep fakes is considered to be
deep face lab if you believe the
examples presented the fake people in
the video turn out as if they were
really alive you can try it yourself by
reading the instructions
and voila we have created a plausible
virtual identity pretty realistic isn't
it we've got several photos of Amanda
posts about her journey and her
portfolio project as a graphic designer
but for now let's do an experiment to
check if Amanda can become a real person
let's see if there are art or design
clubs in London yeah we're going to
apply to each of them it's important to
fill it with details like you're really
passionate about that so you won't be
suspicious so we got accepted to some of
the groups now we're going to write in a
chat and see if someone reacts to our
fake packaging and fake persona
wow Facebook is not dead some girl did
like our fake work let's write to her in
private and see if she finds her
suspicious or not
got you she really accepted my friend
request and agreed on working together
you understand what scammers can do
using a virtual Persona we won't do such
things so we finish our experiment at
this point the experiment of creating a
fake persona really showed the power of
social media and the impact it can have
on our lives so if someone contacts you
in a very nice way completely out of the
blue then take a moment to analyze
whether it's a real or fake person
follow these rules to not get scammed
search by photo many scammers use photos
of real people or stock photos and these
can be found on search engines using the
search by photo feature search the
public data by email address last name
first name and City people leave a lot
of information about themselves on the
internet if there's too little it is
suspicious when communicating with a
person ask them to tell you about their
past childhood Hometown profession catch
the virtual person out for
inconsistencies check the person's
social media profile if it's full of
reposts quotes on images from the
Internet it's likely to be a fake person
carefully examine the details of the
profile photo portraits generated by
neural networks often contain errors for
example accessories the neural network
likes to generate people wearing glasses
and earrings but they often show
artifacts also look at the hair and the
area around the earlobes where you can
often see Distortion blurring around the
edges of the image is another sign of a
neural network generated image because
scammers often use generated portraits
they rarely publish full-length photos
take this into account remember
surviving in the online jungle is not
simple but we some sub will help you see
you in new videos